du côté du ministère de l'intérieur on
planche depuis plusieurs mois pour bâtir
une nouvelle relation entre les forces
de l'ordre et les journalistes sur le
terrain au delà de la polémique autour
de la diffusion des visages des
policiers et gendarmes lier la question
de la présence des journalistes lors des
opérations de maintien de l'ordre
mardi soir certains journalistes qui
couvraient la manifestation devant
l'assemblée nationale ont été menacés
d'interpellations et deux d'entre eux
ont même été placés en garde à vue
invité à réagir gérald darmanin est
revenu sur ces événements je devrais
d'ailleurs dire qu'il ya une personne
notamment à un journaliste qui a fait
savoir d'ailleurs qu'il l'a fait savoir
publiquement qu'il aurait été menacé
d'être interpellé c'est ce genre il ne
s'est pas rapproché de la préfecture de
police de paris contrairement à certains
de ses collègues pour couvrir cette
manifestation je rappelle donc que si
les journalistes couvrent des
manifestations notamment conformément au
schéma de match alors que j'ai évoquées
il doit se rapprocher des autorités en
l'occurrence du préfet du département
singulièrement ici préfet de police de
paris pour se signaler pour être protégé
également parlé par les forces de
l'ordre pour pouvoir être distinguée
pour pouvoir rendre compte dans ce
travail de journaliste dans ces
manifestations
le ministre de l'intérieur ensuite
twitté pour préciser sa pensée
expliquant je cite que les journalistes
peuvent sans en avoir l'obligation
prendre contact avec les préfectures en
amont des manifestations gérald darmanin
fait référence à ce document le schéma
national du maintien de l'ordre publié
le 17 septembre dernier dans lequel on
trouve notamment ses deux passages un
officier référons peut être utilement
désignés au sein des forces et un canal
des changes dédiées mises en place tout
au long de la manifestation avec les
journalistes titulaires d'une carte de
presse accrédités auprès des autorités
il importe à cet égard de rappeler que
le délit constitué par le fait de se
maintenir dans un attroupement après
sommation ne comporte aucune exception y
compris au profit des journalistes ou de
membres d'associations alors obligation
d'accréditation ou non difficile d'y
voir clair à ce stade
voilà en tout cas ce qui explique
l'attitude des forces de l'ordre envers
les journalistes
mardi soir mais ce document est loin de
faire l'unanimité lors de sa parution 40
sociétés de journalistes étaient montés
au créneau contre un texte jugé comme
portant atteinte à la liberté d'informer
cette volonté d'encadrer la profession
de journaliste couplé au controversé
article 24 de la proposition de loi pour
une sécurité globale font craindre à
certains le retour au ministère de
l'information pourtant supprimée en 1974
en france alors sans en arriver jusque
là
le fait de trier des journalistes entre
ceux qui sont autorisés ou non est déjà
en soi une atteinte à la liberté
d'informer même le garde des sceaux a
laissé entendre cette semaine qu'il
voulait réviser la loi de 1881 sur la
liberté de la presse afin de lutter
contre la haine en ligne malgré un
récent rétropédalage du cabinet d'eric
dupond-moretti
voici les arguments exposés par sept
députés de la majorité pour justifier ce
choix devant justement comme une
protection pour les journalistes aussi
pour ceux qui font vraiment leur boulot
qu'ils font un vrai travail
d'investigation qui donne de
l'information et de la vraie information
mais si leur revient au gouvernement de
déterminer qui est journaliste ou qui ne
l'est pas ou encore d'accorder des
autorisations à tel ou tel média pour un
quelconque événement alors on peut
imaginer que certains seraient mis de
côté et on en sait quelque chose